Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192.
David P in this voicemail, our long time caller,
the man has a suggestion for me, and I want
you to weigh in on his suggestion.
The egg man says, David, don't even bother
covering the shootings anymore.
Just don't even bother because nobody's willing
to do anything.
These Republicans won't do a damn thing about
it.
It's just a waste of your breath.
Yes.
Another one and another one.
And they're tragic.
But what else is there to do?
Listen to the egg, man.
Say it.
Speaker 4: Hey, Dave.
Regarding the shooting at the Nashville Christian
private school, three children killed, three
adults killed.
Don't even discuss it.
Skip right over it.
I think that liberals and Democrats are just
wasting our time talking about all these gun
violence and murders and trying to change
gun laws is good.
Literally do nothing.
I'm listening to the mayor speak and he's
acting like, oh, now things are going to change.
This is the same thing every time.
Don't waste one second on this story.
Focus on something that will actually help.
We will never change guns.
The murders will never stop.
The only way they'll stop is when they kill
themselves with their own guns.
So it's a complete waste of time, in my opinion,
to even discuss these shootings.
We should act like they're not even happening.
So what do you think?
Speaker 1: What do you think?
Does the man have a point?
I mean, what he's right about is it's a circle
and it's an endless circle.
And of course, this could just be a show about
mass shootings.
I mean, okay, yesterday we had the shooting
in Nashville, Tennessee, which I covered,
and there was a mass shooting in Milwaukee,
Wisconsin.
And then on Sunday, there were mass shootings
in Philadelphia, Minneapolis, Little Rock,
Arkansas, and Minden, Louisiana.
And then on Saturday, there were mass shootings
in Hempstead, New York, Williamston, North
Carolina, Macomb, Illinois, and Shreveport,
Louisiana.
And then Friday, there was another mass shooting
in Shreveport, Louisiana.
So the point is, every day we could be talking
about these mass shootings, Eggman says.
Even if you don't talk about them at all or
you do talk about them, nothing is going to
change.
So then what's the point?
Asks the AG.
I've laid out 10 to 12 bullet points.
I talked about it at the top of the show of
of rules and laws and policies that could
be put in place to reduce the number of mass
shootings.
There's no willingness whatsoever from Republicans
to institute even a single one of them.
So what is it that we are doing when we acknowledge
these tragedies?
And of course, we only acknowledge some of
them some of them make the national news and
some of them don't.
I don't have the answer, quite frankly.
I'm not pretending to have the answer.
But I understand and sympathize with the man's
frustration.
My question to you is, should these be covered?
Because it seems strange not to seem strange
to pretend that there is no mass shooting
problem in the United States.
At the same time, I understand that we've
been covering these things for over a decade
and very little has changed.
Let me know what you think.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about the new overt.
What would you call it?
Recruiting campaign by Republicans for Senate
candidates that are genuinely filthy rich.
Why is this what they're doing and what way
are they doing it?
We'll talk about it.
Secondly, is Michelangelo's David.
Pornography?
There are some Florida parents who say that
it is, and Italians are inviting the Florida
parents to come check it out for themselves.
And then lastly, a TV anchor named Barbie
Bassett has been fired.
Taken off air, at least I believe, maybe fired.
We'll double check after quoting Snoop Dogg
during a broadcast.
And it was a quote of Snoop Dogg.
Should she have been taken off air?
What should the repercussions be?
Did she do anything wrong?
An uproar about this and it is becoming another
flashpoint in this contrived culture war.
We will talk about all sides of it when producer
Pat joins me on today's bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money.
Everybody else that makes money to fund themselves
is.
Speaker 1: Bad, right?
Let's go make some money on the bonus show.
Okay.
You can sign up at join Pacman dot com.
Coupon code 24 starts now for a discount Every
single day after this show, there's the bonus
show and we can all be thankful for that.